[Music]
welcome back Judy come on do it like you
care welcome back to these gentlemen oh
joy Oh back another week even I here
whatsapp you dye your hair I do not that
it's not ropey Yuki it looks like you
dye your hair well I don't do it I'm not
good I don't honestly how old let's talk
to our guests okay well I just want to
ask you how old I am what do you think I
love that eight how old 58 what did he
got away 40 not true not true how much
do you let our hello your answer hold on
we got a proper instructor if I much
view way and how old you live it I
haven't weighed myself in a while I
think I'm losing my on-screen I am
almost two days off of sweet feeling
good at 45 your 45 yeah wait a minute
you look good wait a minute you look 46
I forgot are you 46 you would look good
for like 62 but they might like if you
take it for your HP relieving doubtful
yeah yeah yeahs talking well all the
work i have distract me from my age
sorry ways falling onto the Warner
Brothers lot distracts me from my here
we go you have a one region that gig in
Vegas for Carlos this weekend if we have
a wonderful wonderful test geez don't
poke the bear we have an absolutely
wonderful get this week on the dojo whoa
I love her I really genuinely love her
uh the one thing I got to say about our
guest is I've always known her in
working at the improv and at the store
and just seeing around at the factory
she's odd all the clubs but we got to
work together with her in Las Vegas yes
absolutely hilarious but the thing I
really appreciate most about our how
hard she works constantly all every you
know you follow somebody you know we all
follow each other on social media always
on stage always grinding always working
and it reminds me of a lot of the guys
and gals that started with in New York
City k quickly
I don't know yeah by the way I don't
follow you thief I probably should you
don't know are you on anything it's a
guy almost 50,000 but Noah's Ark nobody
follows you how many do you have will
let tow some of those people come to
brea okay they are Cavin ticket thank
you for sitting it goes yo you guys are
so funny after we spent that weekend in
Vegas I came back and I was telling
everyone I was like you don't understand
these guys are best friends but there's
such as acquaintances oh sorry ok how
many sets do you do in a week honestly
because you're you're you're always like
doing somewhere yeah now it used to be
more I used to have this thing where it
had to be at least six nights a week
like I wouldn't do less than six but now
I found that the more I'm on the road
I'm not doing quite as many when I'm
back in LA but I still try to do at
least five but you're always weird like
ah have you always had that strong of a
work ethic no matter what it is you are
applying at all kind of has what's yeah
yeah I'm just obsessive about being the
best at whatever it is that I'm doing
not like even necessarily the best like
no maybe not gonna be the best comic but
I'm obsessed with like if I have a goal
I have to get to it and I like can't
help I'm addictive I have an addictive
personality that's all it is so I get
addicted to stand up like I'm addicted
to working out if I did heroin I'd be
like a huge attic immediately I just get
hooked on whatever the thing is there is
addicted to carbs by the way I would not
have guessed that you dyed your hair
couldn't help but then when you brought
it up I was like oh it does look like he
dyes his hair so i'll never forget i
don't mind sharing the story it's pretty
bad what it one of the like second or
third times i had my hair color which
was years ago i went and i went right
before a show i was doing like Carson
Daly or something like that years ago
and what I didn't realize is you should
never get your hair colored on a day
that you have to do something because
what happens is it stains really bad
yeah yeah yeah I got home in my forehead
and black blotches and I am sitting
there in the shower with a washcloth
bitching like it won't come off like
permanent mark
away and so I remember it would be one
time ever the one time that I ended up
wearing a baseball hat to the Carson
Daly show doing warm-up which looks so
weird side never worn a hat before but
it won't come off you literally have to
wait a couple days ago eventually wash
that really yeah I wonder if that
happens with girls or if it's more with
guys because you can see like your scalp
line maybe I've never dyed my hair a
color darker like I just get highlights
so I've never experienced that but I've
also never run into a girl who had like
a stained forehead before I don't know
that happen so but we you and I had
never officially met until vegas because
no obviously it seemed Kate around but
never really officially met or work
together but we were waiting out in
front of the hotel waiting to go to the
club and you just walked up and we just
kind of figured that we were both on the
same show together I was hoping you it
was like you were to standing there with
like two other guys and I was like yeah
there's like hopefully this is them but
also like it's funny because no one
really looks like their photos and
things that are tagged you know so I'm
looking at him and look at the photo
mike is that is that the right guy he's
much thinner though so what well we did
look back at some but we it's always
funny because if you go to Vegas and you
look at when I used to work at the rib
you'd see these old head shots of these
people you're like these aren't even
anybody know who that is okay I do want
to ask you not to get sidetracked from
various great tangent it was a really
amazing those I would like to explore
that real estate book on Kate how
difficult is it or how difficult is that
audience for the avians cuz you you got
to host for the you know it's basically
porn Awards I I would imagine that's got
to be a really difficult audience gig in
general what is it like to hear hey you
got offered this gig and then how do you
prepare for that yeah it was kind of a
scary gig in some ways because there's
really no way to test your jokes
specifically on porn stars you know and
you know you're in that moment so the
way I got it actually a few years ago I
was hanging out with Pauly Shore and his
buddy this guy his name is gary was
uh picking or producing the show that
year and so Paul II introduced me to him
was like I think she'd be a really great
host but I wasn't ready this is like
years ago he was like oh cool yeah will
totally keep an eye on you and then I
forgot all about it I'd never seen the
AVN Awards either some I had no idea I
thought it was like a small thing I
didn't know it was on Showtime I didn't
know was a big production I was then
doing a show at ventura harbor club like
three years later and they came to see
me but they didn't tell me they were
there so a guy from showtime well and a
guy from the avn awards they came up and
i was doing along i was doing like 40
minutes and they watched and then
afterwards they came up to me and they
were like hey we came up here to see if
you would be interested in hosting the
avn awards and I was like what remind me
again what that only I really didn't
even know what I thought was like a bird
show or something like I had no idea and
then they're like the porn Awards in Las
Vegas it's on showtime and I was like oh
my god yeah that'd be really cool so I
said yes they gave me like two months to
prepare okay yeah so that's a lot of
time so right away I wrote like 15
minutes of porn jokes kind of but my big
thing with them is I was like I didn't
want to be super dirty I was like I want
to do this in a way where i come off as
like the clueless kind of right yeah
girld it doesn't know what I'm about
porn cuz I really didn't and they were
like yeah you can do whatever you want
you know I I didn't even have to really
run my jokes by them I mean they well
yeah I was pretty surprised and and what
I did is I guess it's like when when
best anal is being presented it's like
yeah I don't think I'm really going to
toe the line with my material exactly I
mean that's the thing is that the whole
show is hilarious and the big question I
had is how much of a sense of humor will
the porn first have about themselves
yeah what did you find they were awesome
you know a lot of comments warned me
they were like they're terrible they're
going to be a bad crowd don't play to
them play to the viewers at home I
didn't really do that but you guys just
worked with me now like I have to talk
to the audience some I can't ignore them
I just can't so I ran the jokes I was
gonna do it the porn Awards I ran them
everywhere for like a month leading up
to it now would just ask the audience
really try to imagine your porn star and
then when I got there I just did a tiny
bit of crowd work at the top and I named
some of the porn stars and they cut that
out of the show but that got them on my
side right and then it was fun it was
fine they were great they were like the
girls I think when I came out on stage
immediately supported because they were
like oh she could be one of us like I
think that's what they honestly thought
I think they were like confused like and
the guys to the guys I think we're like
is that one of us or is that a comic
like no one knew so I I had the best
time then what did you have any
preconceived notions about the community
prior to and then afterwards a different
kind of totally I don't you know we
imagine porn actors as the at least I
did I grew up in conservative Midwest
Ohio I just imagined it like all porn
actors were going to be like damaged
drug addicts and like kids that were
abused honestly that's what I thought in
my head but a lot of them are just like
normal cool like very open minded and
just they're just like well I just
really like sex and they say like do
that you know do a job that you would do
for free so here I at like a lot of them
were just normal people that happen to
do porn which I thought was fascinating
also a lot of the happiest married
couples I've ever met my life yeah
they're like both porn people like
there's this couple annika albrite and
mick blue they're adorable they're like
the cutest couple there they've been
porn stars together for years and they
told me this story how like one year
they won best best anal sex scene in a
motion picture or something that is our
place has been driving for they want it
together and then they came on stage and
they were both like crying and their
parents were there I know I know and she
was like she was like but it was so
sweet as my first anal scene I got to do
with my husband and I mean it's weird as
[ __ ] don't get me wrong it's super weird
but the longer you're there and the more
of them you meet you start to go alright
well this is a unique little world both
of them but they're happy in it yeah
yeah they don't
trapped there that's what I'm saying but
you remember the one of the last night
that we were in Vegas we did the QA with
the audience Alexa yes you went out the
audience and you did a QA and then you
start talking to these people at the
very end of the night there were what 12
people in the audience that did porn
yeah and they're talking him we're like
well what do you do when he's like well
I designed the sets like I said that
yeah that dr. like they really have a
job like that I mean I there really is i
don't know as i'm with a classroom i
mean like yeah he said he has yes stock
principal stuff stock classroom stuff
that was crazy it's so weird though
because I've been on porn sets because
what he said that to me when we were in
Vegas never been on a porno set and I
was like no but where would I buddy is
really I don't know why looking down on
the horn outside like what's wrong there
you how have you lived this long ever
knew McDonald never done Star Wars know
what I mean what is it like um well it
kind of ruined porn for me now like I
can barely watch you know it's like when
you're really good friends with an actor
and you try to watch them in a show and
it's hard to like see them unless
they're like so brilliant you forget
that you know I yeah it's like that was
porn for me now because it's not from
the ABN because I hosted a show in the
Playboy channel where we would explore
different like fetishes and stuff and so
we had to go on some porn sets and it's
like it's just weird because they shoot
it the same way that you shoot a TV show
where it's like they have a storyboard
I'm not kidding they have a storyboard
and they have to get different angles
inos here like this is going to be the
close-up of her giving head this is
going to be then they stop down a lot
you know so it's like it's not like you
think we're like if it's a [ __ ] scene
like the girl just gives them like a
crazy [ __ ] till it's like no there's
lots of stopping down and like retaining
positions and lights and so like the
girls trying to stay what and the guys
shooting up his dick with like drugs
he's jerking off by himself in a corner
and
I mean I use most of them actually use
drugs now you're really supplements yeah
and it is the crew like very
professional like nobody like everybody
taking this like they're filming it's
very hairy i have a photo i wanted to
treat i wanted to treat yeah that's a
good a big bang um I wanted to treat
this photo so grab my girlfriend sent it
to me and it's from importance I would
like obviously have friends now that
work in that business my friend who
works important sent me a photo and it's
of a guy and he's banging a girl and
they're like next to a pool and then
there's a camera guy and then there's a
guy holding like you know the light the
light reflector thing and they're
standing there and the camera guy is
holding the camera but he's looking at
his watch I know light and the guy
holding the reflector board is holding
it but he's just like staring off like
neither of them are looking yet the
people thought and that that room he is
like yeah what I saw the most when I was
on new sets it's so weird i wonder how
often like these houses get rented out
you know especially here in LA and
people because i knew a buddy that lived
in the hills and he said oh 3 doors over
they were shooting a movie a couple of
days ago like it was no big deal
immunity yeah but you're just shooting
out the middle of nowhere just you know
i mean i gotta film those somewhere well
some of those houses they use over and
over again for porn yeah like there was
a house that we went to there's a house
I don't know how I know the most about
porn for someone that has never done
porn by the way there was a house that
we shot an episode of my show at it was
like on virtual reality porn dude the
sickest house i've ever seen and i've
been to like NBA players houses and [ __ ]
this house had a racquetball court in it
inside the house with basketball hoops
and stuff they had two pools like a huge
fountain in the backyard a tennis court
like I mean it was like Aaron Spelling's
house and all they were just what it
needs I missing you know the ball court
right up [ __ ] in all right and the crazy
thing is you walk in there and it's like
the house is so stunning but then I was
like where can I sit for sure that
hasn't been [ __ ] on like what I don't
touch anything do they have to bring
their own furniture though I mean like I
wouldn't want to leave my couch there I
mean today or do they put a sheet on it
or something they don't want a sheet on
it but I think that they just I don't
think anyone really like lives there i
think this is all they use it for well
if they need to [ __ ] in like a 600
square foot apartment that here by Cox
and more doors in our parking yeah i can
write that out right well that'd be they
were kind of porn like the dogs to be
licking their buttholes I mean any we're
logging that you're doing a new show on
MTV too oh yeah I'm on the show called a
DD TV right yeah it'll be on mtv2 you
know yeah comes out februari third
1130pm so that is i work with all def
digital a lot which is Russell Simmons
network and it's an online network they
have like okay i have now like a million
a half subscribers or something on
youtube but uh mtv picked up a show of
theirs so it's going to be a lot of like
sketches and just funny we do weird
stuff on there like that will hook us up
to lie detectors and ask us questions
like the other day I did one is it true
pretty girls or shallow so they hook you
up to a lie detector and then they ask
you questions like would you date a guy
with no job and then you know they
discover whether or not you're shallow
it's like weird stuff like that yeah it
turns out I'm a little shallow but I
mean the thing is so they're like would
you date a guy with no job and I'm like
no yeah I don't think that makes me
shallow thinks it just makes me have
standards sure you know yeah he has
house up and he he can work as like you
know Chipotle guy like I would date that
guy starbucks guy we would ever be then
he's got this work anyway I want to have
God it's a serious question right a very
attractive girl but do you know when Inc
it when you go into like let's say this
obviously you get work on the road right
you always have to worry about like
headliners asking you to go on the road
because you think sometimes it might be
for the wrong reasons not always but
sometimes yeah happens a lot less now
because people know but maybe when
you're first starting yeah people are
like hey she might not be that funny yet
yeah are to take her on the road be your
mentor but also affect something in
return yeah you know how guys are well
when it when I mean like there's two
different kinds of guys that will take
you on the road when you first start and
one is the guy that's like he wants to
help you out and give you the work and
he's hoping maybe you'll bang him okay
and then there's the guy that's like
I'll take you but you're gonna bang me
like there's I mean there was a guy
honestly when I first started out I've
never told the story there was one guy
who hit me up and I knew it was to say
you know as a comic like when someone's
asking you to feature and they've never
even when you write and upper year and
you're like why is this guy asking me I
see me yeah a guy asked me to feature
for him a weekend and I thought it was
strange and I'd never featured before
and I barely knew him and everything and
then he was like you know but you gotta
um you ought to share a room with me you
know as long as you're cool with that
and then I said I said well here's the
thing I go I'd love to come and I'm
totally gone left the counter would add
haha but I said I have a lot of hotel
points because I work on the road a lot
so I like rubber so I'll just get a room
and then the next day he texts me was
like y'all you know what the club said
no ah so I mean in that case I'll good
yeah but to be honest it doesn't happen
that often I mean it really doesn't at
least not to me because you've proven
yourself though to get work on your own
you but I would think early on that's
got to be a big thing well I always say
that any cute girl in comedy is like
Chum in the water yeah any cute girl
that comes into this circle because it's
just a bunch of guys you know the guys
hope they all attacked that I mean I you
can see it happen you can literally see
it happen when there's a new girl like
every guy starts hitting her up but for
me it's like I dated I did date two
comics but both of them I like dated and
I'm not many people ever knew and we
never work together like I kept it when
I did date them I was like I never want
us working together because I never want
people to think that that kept going on
but i have never just like I don't hook
up with comics as a rule so I think that
gets around people go oh you bet you
will took her on the road you bang her
nod it and then they just start to
realize you're not doing that so right I
don't yeah it does have to be just a
challenging situation especially for
females the guy it is well no the one
thing that you said when we were working
together in Vegas I i just i'd never
thought about it before us iconic that's
really interesting and I think obviously
there's so it look it's a tough enough
gig as it is being a stand-up being a
woman I just I think it's just that much
more difficult because you're constantly
having to prove yourself and you had
said something we're backstage one day
it was like I can't remember exactly how
you said it but you were looting cayenne
pepper spray but it was like you were
thinking about like what it is you you
were wearing or something like that yeah
it was just like that's such a
interesting thing because because I like
Whitney Cummings is somebody and one of
when you were talking I was like one of
the greatest introductions I ever got
was from when he comes at the comedy
store shoes bring him up and she goes
this is a guy that helped me out early
on and he never tried to [ __ ] me and I
thank her for that Steve barn I was like
oh that's cool it's true it's true like
I mean the guys like that like you like
Joey Diaz Sam Tripoli there are guys
that have been like super supportive of
me and helped me and never there's never
been any hint of that and like women we
do tell other comics like I will tell
other girl comics be like no no no steve
is like so stand up or like Joey dia
like people even asked me after my
weekend with Joey Diaz people always ask
so I Oh is he trying to get it in like
no he's just a good there are some guys
who are some good God yeah how please
however how difficult is it like I mean
as a girl you know you and especially
you you're very beautiful you work out I
mean it's like do you wear like a skirt
and heels and then is that distracting
from the audience to to listen your
jokes or do you dress down you just like
you know a sweatshirt and jeans and then
it's like III never had to worry about
what I'm wearing on stage but I think
for girls it is something where you're
being judged not only by the girls
you're judged by the guys as well and
then what is the best way to facilitate
the jokes and be yourself and yeah it is
crazy how that's something I still
struggle it for this day is like what to
wear sometime een Erik Griffin gave me
the best advice once which is he just
said dress in whatever makes your act
the funniest like dress for your act and
then for me that's like I like to dress
a little more innocent on stage which
isn't necessarily up or down just a
little more like wholesome looking
because then when I do dirtier material
it makes it funnier to me like the
juxtaposition but I can't go on stage
dressed hot wearing heels I just can't
but that's also not really my
personality yeah like I like to draw
everybody likes to look good so like I
like to dress hot sometimes and have fun
but people see my Instagram and stuff
especially when I was working on the
Playboy show and they think that I'm
like the girl and like hot outfits was
makeup all the time and stuff but I'm
really like much more of a tomboy in
real life so it's kind of nice or not
shooting the Playboy show because I can
really just wear like my regular clothes
and right it wasn't funny because we
talked about this in Vegas when I saw
you you do something in your act where
you're trying in a funny way to pick up
a guy in the audience right yeah so you
say so many times after the show the guy
will come up to be like hey I was the
gun like her I'm on stage trying to pick
up a woman she couldn't be further out
to the parking lot you're squealing her
tires tonight you I would think you know
hey I'm the guy it's just like how do
you cross that we're bridge my act is
weird because on one hand that happens
like I do always flirt with a guy or
girl it's me i'm not a Leslie Jones yeah
and so like it is hilarious because
almost within 24 hours of any set almost
I'd say ninety nine percent of time I
will get a message from that guy on
social media hey I was the guy in the
front row whatever
her but the flip side of that is my
whole the whole path I've taken with my
career has destroyed my dating life just
really drew it yes especially my
apologize because you know I do a
podcast yeah and it's about dating and
sex and I talk about my personal life
holiday fails cod date fail yeah and uh
like I had a great day a couple weeks
ago with this guy that like great date
great make out totally headed off and
then I didn't hear from him again and
then I finally was like hey what's up
like a good time and he's like I'm just
really worried you're gonna talk about
me on your podcast oh wow yeah and I'm
like [ __ ] this is probably happening
more than I even know like guys are
going out and I'm probably I don't know
why but I had a guy come to a show in
Phoenix and by the guy to a show and I
never do that I want to date him because
I do a lot of material about being crazy
and then come to see that and that's
exactly what everybody this guy to show
we're like kind of cozying up hanging
out in the greener like things are going
good we never met in person before I'm
like I'll he totally intimacies great
and then I was like I gotta go up and do
my set but i'll be back in a half hour I
go on stage a comeback completely
different energy I swear to God you
barely touch me you barely talked to me
and i was like he totally thinks I'm
crazy now guys don't get that like that
yeah I mean I am crazy of course I'm a
girl but like it's embellished but they
don't get it so yeah I've decided that
I'm gonna have to choose between being
successful as a comic and having sex not
gonna buy some guy that's gonna that's
gonna see your rack and go this chicks
great and accepting for you yeah that
reminder this one time I perform I met
this girl in New York City and she's
like only live in Florida and they're
like two months later I was doing this
college in Florida and I hit her up like
a I'm gonna be down to flourish I'm
doing the show when she comes she goes
okay I didn't know is going to be like
an outdoor festival only know I I
remember they set up a stage there was
this huge outdoor place they had like a
rock
on your wall on human foosball and all
that stuff and they set up a stage on
the home plate in a baseball field and
then they put bleachers in the left
outfield a fright outfield so you're not
even near the audience that's so awkward
I think they thought like you too was
going to be it's like why why we why
don't you put chairs in front of this I
don't understand it so I'm performing
and there's like six people in these
bleachers like my name is bleachers and
the girl is sitting in the bleachers I'm
doing I'm telling you ten minutes in my
act you could hear her not even just see
her clink down those aluminum heirs of
the thing and I could watching her walk
cuz i'm outside right watch her walk all
the way through the whole thing up into
the parking lot into her heart december
from a whole time i'm like dying inside
but do the whole thing you say anything
like I sure I was eating it I was dying
on in a baseball field yeah part of this
kink off was one of the work oh that's
fantastic form never well I met her
after my show yes so she'd see me at
like in New York City but not in a
[ __ ] baseball field right [ __ ] ate
my ass people don't have people who get
like I was dating a guy that because I
don't ever let guide and eight income
like that was the first time I ever
invited a guy was risk if you Lana well
I was like it's the only way I'm enough
time to see those guys we've been
talking every time I'm in town but we
never hung out this is in Phoenix but
like I never let guys I date come and
sometimes it drives him crazy some of
them get it but I was dating this one
guy and he like kept insisting on coming
and finally I go all right I'll tell you
what you can come with me to the Laugh
Factory you sit upstairs I just don't
want you in the audience right why just
get upstairs that's fine and he showed
up like six of his buddies and bought
VIP front-row tickets oh no that in the
crime and it was like I had I just I
can't do it because the whole time I'm
like thinking in my head like oh how is
he going to deal with it how's what guys
should i pick out a guy like it the
whole thing mess with my head
and afterwards I was like oh that was so
awful he was quitting time but it was
great it was fine i was so funny and i
was like if you ever come here again I
will never talk I was so mad but you
said to you didn't know he was even in
the front row true you got on no I
didn't know he did that yeah yeah the
last thing you want is somebody you know
or dating or family you don't want them
in the front you go in the back yeah sit
upstairs like it are you yeah exactly
always but and you're worried about not
only the audience much so you take the
high nice idea but you're worried about
not only what he thinks but then you're
thinking or his buddy's gonna glom on to
be like hey we didn't like her we did it
like and now all of a sudden he's
feeding into what they're thinking yeah
I mean just the whole thing is just
awkward because it's like you don't you
want to be up there like free as a bird
and be able to do in the moment and say
anything and you don't want to have this
extra layer of like what is this guy
going to think about this joke and it
was just it was the word maybe it you
know was good for the avian maybe that
was better that you didn't know that
they were there to on the flip side
because that's why you got the gig you
were so comfortable when you did that
show hundred percent and also what was
so great is the the guys when they came
up to ventura harbor club they said oh
we really wanted to see you outside of
LA so we could see how real people react
to regular people not an industry crowd
which I was like wow that's really cool
that they did them yeah the atms of soap
no would you do it again I would yeah it
was really fun i had a good time it'd be
it'd be more difficult to second time
but it'd be fun though because now I
dated a guy that works in that industry
and I have friends in the industry now
so now would be very different was like
the first time I knew nothing about it
now I could definitely do like had
primarily been guys hosting it like it i
always remember like being like dave
attell hosted it yeah I think Ralphie
may host a minute and get it yeah I hope
I think yeah they had guys for a while
and then they had a few years where it
was girl girl girl like April Macie did
it Rebecca cochin and then this year
they went back to a guy they just they
just did it in January and calling Cain
hosted okay yeah which I'm friends with
Colin so I mean I was like Colin is
perfect for that he's super dirty
already so what'swhat's like bigger
picture for you like you know five years
like what do you you know
working the road is a stand-up a host
what would hoping to uh not be living my
car no I'm just kidding no I mean like
my it's always changing you know what's
funny is I used to always say I want to
have a sitcom and then work the road
Rhino weekends right but it's kind of
lately been shifting for me a little bit
because I look at guys like Joe Rogan
and Joey Diaz who have these huge
followings who are basically producing
their own content like the podcast right
and so now I'm kind of looking at it
like the digital I mean there's so many
things you can do online that now it's
still the same thing I still want to
have a show I still want to have my
podcast I still want to work the road
but if I could produce everything on my
own and have a huge following that way
like five years from now to be able to
be creating lots of content and just
have a huge fan base and be able to go
out on the road and work I think would
be amazing I think there is that myth
and I'm being jolly serious with you for
a second but there is that myth that
comics about to LA everybody wants to do
a sitcom I remember that first move to
LA everybody was in town from january to
march i'm here for pilot season you're
like what the hell's that then you find
out they didn't do [ __ ] like I would
never live in Long Beach I got to be up
for auditions and these people that are
never I did right right but what you
find out is that if you've been on any
sitcom set for any length of time it's a
grind I mean you know that when you did
it for three seasons yeah it's a lot of
work I mean it really is i mean i just
see it on these shows that i do right
it's a lot of work I mean it's a lot of
stress a lot of aggravation worried
about the numbers the best job in a
sitcom is those side characters like you
know that you're the neighbors or
whatever I mean because those gigs pay a
lot you can still on the road you can
filter you like a kevin nealon or a
Patton Oswalt like those guys had the
greatest gigs but when the show falls on
your shoulders that's a lot right i mean
for what it is yeah but any job there's
always going to be that pressure or
success but i think it's you know how
much did that pressure do you want how
much how much do you want to lead the
charge I'm sure Rogan has pressure first
you to keep that network going the same
way bill byrne al magical have pressure
to keep this going but it's like do you
want
own the corporation or do you want to
work for the corporation so I think it's
admirable to say I want to open my own
business I want to I want to be my own
boss and produced that own content
because I mean nowadays everything's
changed like you said it's all shifting
so much dramatically that's right I mean
how many times have we been to an improv
were funny bone and then during the
afternoon they have some YouTube star
you've never heard of I like they just
did two back-to-back shows no material
but they sold out it's like yeah we're
professional comedians with real jokes
and you know you're it's a struggle some
some markets to get anybody to come out
but yeah it's all different yeah i mean
that's honestly like I love Joey Diaz so
much and when I worked with him last
weekend I came back and I was like just
really inspired from talking to him
about how hard he grinds on his podcast
and on his periscope and on social media
and how much of that has turned over for
him into attendance at his shows but
also like he's such a smart business guy
and that's the thing I think a lot of
people come out to LA like you're saying
Gary and they're just like I'm here I
got an agent I'm not going to chill out
go to auditions and it's like the people
that are becoming huge stars with people
that are just grinding away and making
contact with their fans and building
their own audience yeah and that's the
other thing for me like I spend a lot of
time interacting back with the people
that follow me maybe a little too much
sometimes but those people show up you
know those are people that buy
merchandise and there's the people that
listen to your podcast like religiously
and and so you can almost build your own
little like grass like mini you know
grass movement out there it is funny
because i remember when i started doing
stand-up in San Francisco everybody said
don't go to LA until you're ready you
need 30 great minutes you need this you
need that and then when you come down to
your life said no you don't you're
you're like people have five minutes I
mean it really is crazy I mean I see you
know people who get spots on you know
different TV shows and you know they
can't go headline on the road they're
not strong comics yeah so it's like
there is that variation of it yeah well
and also you have to love it too
you know what I mean because like
nobody's getting rich off comedy for a
very long time you know so if you don't
love it and you give up after a year or
two because they're not making like I
just really enjoy it it's my favorite
thing to do to make comedy and I mean
stand up and videos and just any dumb
goofy [ __ ] that I post like I people ask
me they're like what do you like to do
for fun when you're not doing comedy
stuff and I'm like that is like my
favorite fun like that that is fun so I
have to ask you because I do follow you
on Instagram are you actually good at
tennis yeah I'm pretty okay how do you
get all your like a rooster outfit
jumping around and I passport and then
the next week gets in a back in and then
I it's just like I wonder if she just
does she live by a tennis quarters
you're actually playing are you good
well oddly I've not that is one in a
bikini photo I've never actually done is
the tennis one another one at home depot
the other day oh yeah that was an old
one but I just I posted it cuz uh I your
screensaver yeah yeah no I do play
tennis I when I moved to LA the
apartment that I lived in over by the
beach had tennis courts and a tennis pro
who would give you free lessons both
routes yeah so I started playing and I'm
obsessed and by the way since Steven our
big fan of the bachelor will you tell us
your pastor audition story oh I went to
audition for I i went to audition for
the bachelor bikini but the joke was and
I periscope did so I have a I do a lot
of weird stuff on periscope but I went
to audition for the bachelor I pretended
I didn't know they were having auditions
it was at that casino out by palm
springs I forget what it's called wrongo
morongo casino yet so I went there as
winter I had on a bikini and my friend
and I we pretended like we were
wandering by the audition and we told
them we were just coming back from the
pool and they were like oh really would
you like to audition and I was like oh I
don't know I didn't I didn't plan for
that I'm in a bikini and the funny thing
is that no one questioned the fact the
pool was closed but uh but they gave us
this they gave me this huge form to fill
out and I did they were like you no
reason you're single and I was like see
photo and they took like a polar
right of me in a bikini and then and
then I went in and I auditioned and they
were like it are you doing this as a
joke and I was like no it's might always
been my dream to be The Bachelorette I
didn't want to be on The Bachelor I
wanted to be on the best I wanted to
beat the bad oreca guys yeah but anyway
they were like well we were all drawing
straws in the back over who got to
interview you because we just thought
you seemed crazy and but then they did
call me and asked me if I wanted to be
on this season of The Bachelor oh wow
yeah but i said no i only wanted to be
the Bachelorette right ironically i know
this bachelor and I knew the last
bachelor also how thank you know Nick I
mean yeah we we just dm'd a little bit
because I matched with them on a dating
app like a probably year and a half ago
that's it what we're saying that he's a
professional that's all he does is he
just a bachelor Tully yeah he's a
professional bad yeah there's several of
these guys yeah I've been on like
multiple seasons of this show I don't
get I don't get it Nick drives me crazy
you guys are watching right yeah okay I
actually watch this season I've never
watched before and I just I don't
understand the show I can't get behind
it I don't is the most insulting season
to a viewer like all the the haunted
house [ __ ] that they did i'm like
what is it's so bad now contrived i
absolutely hate it but a lot of exercise
yes so i can't stand how he makes out he
made out with every girl by episode to
air over whenever I just I hate it I'm
like this is gross it's like well I'm
girl a nice a girl last night said if
that's all he's thinking with his dick
then i'm free to go home it's like you
went home bachelor in paradise exactly
Steven I literally get together every
Monday or Tuesday were watching code and
desserts and all that great [ __ ] and
then we watch it but his wife is there
to offset kind of the game is no that's
that's good I don't understand these
girls that are like are you here to find
love or just a hookup it's like he's
dating 30 of you at once why you think
he's here but no one is you're looking
for a wife like these girls are
delusional if they think that well
that's why we really thought when we
watched last year when
but yeah who picked a girl as arbiter
and rod oh the Bachelorette yes and then
that guy Chad yeah who was the most
honest who's great he was right on a
date him oh my god so I don't allow them
once for the experience go on a date I
don't know you want a date no I want a
hug a tree real estate luxury real
estate agent in Oklahoma yeah or
Arkansas something yeah real luxury real
estate in highrise yeah that's
overlooking the downtown well Kate we
cannot thank you enough where can people
find you oh you guys can just follow me
on everything at Kate q funny and date
fails here on atc as well yes yes i love
all things I don't wait we had such a
great time when we worked with Kate in
Vegas that I hope that we have something
coming up again with yeah yeah it's so
fun don't know much fun the most fun
I've ever had Jay fails all things
you're right buddy you're right no we'll
do another one I love it I love working
with you who's so fun me too music thank
you um gentleman's dojo k quickly check
her out on date fails and a DD TV on
mtv2 right and just a DDT VF every third
1130pm mtv2 um Gary where can accompany
it doesn't I am God thank you so much
gentlemen's dojo
[Music]